le parti progressiste martiniquais un
nouvel ennemi venu à l'ennemi c'est
l'état local parce que la préfecture la
martinique n'assume pas ses
responsabilités et ne fait pas son
travail
pour quelles raisons qui vous dire ça
peut-être que c'est parce que nous
avions une excédent 2015 que nous avons
laissé cet excédent a été reconnue par
trois juges de la chambre régionale des
comptes s'est dit excédé a été reconnu
par à-coups des coques ou ce didier
migaud avec des lacs des rapports
monsieur le préfet rigoulet ge n'a
jamais fait le travail qui je peux pas
le faire pourrait intégrer
l'excédent alors que ce monsieur a
décrété et déclaré qu'il ya 23 millions
de dhs et physique
cela n'a jamais été intégré dans aucun
budget après 2015 ni dans aucune
décision modificative
c'est une fête administrative de
monsieur rigoulet roze thorpe a fait son
travail
des poussées à monsieur marie-jeanne
d'intégrer les rosen nous le sommes
battus cet excédent la paille d'intégrer
monsieur feu combines qui est arrivé
cela fait près de deux ans la chebel
fait intégrer l'excédent alors que la
non intégration de l'excédent fait que
tous les budgets qui sont votées après
2015 sont entachées d'irrégularités bien
je me suis posé la question au ministère
notamment monsieur darmanin ministre du
budget je me suis posé la question
auprès de la ministre de l'outre-mer
pour dire qu'est-ce qui se passe pour
quelles raisons n'étaient pas l'excédent
des droits pour quelles raisons les lois
de la république ne sont pas respectées
parce qu'ils doivent faire respecter les
lois ce qui met retourné et que j'ai
ressenti être alors les lettres les
déclarations du molde fait pas de vagues
en martinique
c'est son costume de l'état et deuxième
chose
ce monsieur de viol en bravant de bonnes
relations avec lui
il faut surtout pas lui chercher des
histoires
la martinique est tombé très bas
la martinique est soumis à une violence
politique
budgétaire la martinique est semi haine
violence économique
pour quelle raison je le dis je le
répète encore parce qu'en laissant un
message est que l'état cautionne ce
manceau joie c'est son mensonge qu'il
présente de tous les lentilles de 15 en
dix ans il n'y a pas d'argent c'est pour
ça qu'on peut pas investir ces fonds il
y a de l'ange ans et on peut investir
les obus est là